أوكيناوا اليابان، سردينيا، إيطاليا،
شبه جزيرة نيكويا في كوستاريكا، إيكاريا، اليونان،
ولوما ليندا، كاليفورنيا، هي
المناطق الزرقاء، خمسة أماكن يعيش فيها الناس
أطول فترة، وهم الأكثر صحة، ولكن
السؤال هو لماذا اسمحوا لي أن أختار أحد
هذه الأماكن وسأختار فقط
شبه جزيرة نيكويا في كوستاريكا، ما هو الأمر المتعلق بهذه
البيئة، كما تعلم لا توجد
رصاصة فضية في أي من هذه المناطق الزرقاء،
أسميها رصاصة فضية، ما الذي
يفعلونه بشكل جيد أولاً وقبل كل شيء، فهم يتناولون
نظامًا غذائيًا أساسيًا من أمريكا الوسطى أو لديهم
معظم الوقت  من حياتهم والتي تتكون من
ثلاثة أطعمة، أعتقد أنها أفضل الأنظمة الغذائية التي
اخترعها البشر على الإطلاق، حبوب الذرة
والقرع، يمكن لأي شخص أن يوفر لهم نسبة عالية من
الكربوهيدرات المعقدة، ونسبة
عالية من النياسين، وحمض الفوليك الذي كان يمثل حوالي 80 بالمائة
من نظامهم الغذائي، لذا فهذا جزء منه.
جميع المناطق الزرقاء كانت بعيدة عن
بقية كوستاريكا، لديهم 30 أو 40
عامًا في انتظارك، كما تعلم بداية ظهور
مطاعم الوجبات السريعة ورقائق البطاطس والمشروبات الغازية
والسيارات التي لم يقودها أي من هؤلاء المعمرين، لقد
ساروا طوال
حياتهم  إنها إضافة
النظام الغذائي الصحيح، البيئة الاجتماعية المناسبة،
البيئة المادية المناسبة التي
تنتج هذه الأرقام الضخمة غير العادية لمتوسط
العمر المتوقع، يمكن
أن ما وصفته للتو في
شبه جزيرة نيكويا يمكن تكييفه، ليس فقط
يمكن تكييفه، ولكن كما تعلم، خذ فورت وورث
تكساس نحن  عملنا هناك لمدة خمس سنوات،
وبعد خمس سنوات ضد ضوابط ولاية تكساس،
شهدنا انخفاضًا في السمنة بنحو ثلاثة
بالمائة من الرضا عن الحياة، وزاد
استهلاك الخضروات، وزاد
النشاط البدني، ليس لأننا دخلنا
وحاولنا إقناع لحوم البقر المجنونة في فورت
وورث بتناول المزيد  الفاصوليا ولكن لأننا
ذهبنا إلى جميع المطاعم والمدارس ومحلات
البقالة
وأقنعناهم بجعل الأطعمة الصحية
أرخص وأكثر سهولة، جعلنا
المدينة تعتمد سياسات لجعل تلك المدينة
أكثر قابلية للمشي وأكثر قابلية للدراجات، وقد
نجح الأمر الآن، أليس كذلك؟  منطقة زرقاء كاملة مثل
سردينيا لا ولكننا حصلنا عليها بنسبة 10 إلى 15
بالمائة من الطريق نحو المنطقة الزرقاء،
فبدلاً من التركيز على
الأدوية أو خطة رعاية صحية أفضل
أو كما تعلمون بعض العلاجات المضادة للشيخوخة،
نظرنا ببساطة إلى البيئات
المناطق الزرقاء وحاولنا تطبيقها على
سياق أمريكي وهي ناجحة في كل
مرة جربناها